have you ever bought a digital Xbox game
and wanted your money back well it
sounds like digital refunds that
something Microsoft is going to let you
take advantage of in the future I'm Matt
and this game spot News Update is non
refundable information on the new refund
program was issued to those
participating in the Xbox insider
program which lets members test new
features before they're made available
to everyone an image of the information
was posted on reddit and it says that
Microsoft is planning to offer refunds
for digital products on the Company's
website a second image was posted to
NeoGAF which taught us that any product
bought within the past 14 days and
played for less than two hours is
eligible DLC season passes and add-ons
however are not refundable there's
currently no word on when the new refund
program will be made available to
everyone
steam has offered refunds on the PC with
similar guidelines since 2015 but
Microsoft will be the first to do
something like this on console we'll
report back when more information is
revealed so make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to stay up on all the Xbox
news and if you want to learn more about
Microsoft's next console check out our
video on the six things you need to know
about project Scorpio
[Music]